the libs are trying to cancel a kid at a
Kansas City Chief's game for allegedly
wearing black face yesterday dead spin
demanded quote the NFL needs to speak
out against the Kansas City Chiefs fan
in blackface native headdress they're
doubling up on racism the outlet wrote
are you going to say anything Roger
Goodell now the fan in question was a
little kid and while the picture that
the outlet used showed him in profile
with black paint on his face a picture
from the front shows that he had painted
his face half black and half red that is
in the team's
colors he also wore a
headress because it's the Kansas City
Chiefs the journalists who ran this are
obviously totally awful despicable
little left-wing cretans for picking on
this kid
but the conservatives are missing
something too because the conservative
defense of this kid thus far has largely
been confined to the observation that he
wasn't actually wearing
blackace that is weak sauce because the
deeper error in the libs attack is that
contrary to what the left selectively
argues today there is nothing inherently
wrong about blackface at all I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nlls Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by good ranchers head
over to goodranchers.com to find all
your gifts this year use code nolles to
save a bonus of 10% today on top of
their December sale Mitt Romney would
rather th vote for a Democrat than for
Trump or V ramaswami we'll get to that
in a second first though I don't want to
move on too quickly from what is almost
guaranteed to be my Media Matters
highlight clip of the day which is that
there's nothing inherently wrong with
blackface and it's just a fact
and I think it's ridiculous that anyone
even pretends to contradict this today
you don't need to take my word for it
here is proof that there is nothing
inherently wrong with blackface care of
I don't know the
last however many decades you can
possibly remember from Hollywood
Sammy Sammy great there we go
there's there's Billy Crystal as Samy
Davis Jr and a b
count great impression man I got to tell
you babe my body is my temple there's
Jimmy Kim asob workout I seen who
millionaire and guess what not a lot of
black folks on the show Jimmy Fallon is
Chris Rock hilarious it's a great
you know why cuz black folks don't like
to answer questions you serious you
don't know one of the great performances
ever Robert Danny Jr everybody knows he
never go full I look like the
beautiful queen L Sarah Silverman not as
great a performance but she's doing a
blackface kind of joke there too you're
a genius
Eddie John Slattery and Mad Men doing a
full-on swanie blackface minstral
performance and the are
gay I certain on enough space on the
train for me with Eddie Murphy n ningo
from Cameroon do you remember me it's
Lionel
Joseph
Lionel so a lot of times conservatives
will point to these clips whenever some
lib calls us racist we point to these
clips and we say so no you're the real
racists cuz you did blackface but I
actually don't see anything wrong with
any of those performances any of them
not one they were all fine even from the
libs even Jimmy Kimmel making fun of
Oprah that was funny even Sarah
Silverman which is the edgiest one there
cuz she's doing actual like grease
blackface minstral show performance it's
obviously ironic what she's doing she's
obviously making a a commentary on it
it's totally fine now now people draw a
distinction they will say well there's a
difference between doing an impression
of an actual black person and doing
blackface in the old minstral tradition
and I agree and certainly Jimmy Fallon
doing an impression of Chris Rock is
much more easily defended than someone
doing you know an old Al Jolson number
but I I wouldn't even write off the Al
Jolson numbers so quickly here here's
why most people who attack blackface you
do so in a really convenient way to
score some cheap political Point like
they're trying to attack a kid at a
Kansas City Chiefs game but how many
know the actual history of it people
think that blackface was merely a
performance of white people to make fun
of carat of black people that isn't true
so if we're going to cancel blackface
even the most difficult to defend the
old minstral theatrical tradition are we
going to cancel Billy
kersands Billy kersands is a name if
you've ever heard it you've probably
only ever heard of it on this show Billy
crans was one of the most famous
minstral performers ever in American
history and he was a black guy and he
did blackface but he was a black guy and
very successful thespian writer comedian
performer he came up with the ant Jima
character which also got canceled later
on by liberal white people because they
said it was racist or something canceled
a black character portrayed by a black
woman written by a black comedian no has
to go away because the white liberals
don't like it anymore should we cancel
Billy kurand should we cancel an entire
major form of the American theatrical
tradition are we going to cancel The
Jazz Singer it's the first talkie ever
starring Al Jolson because it has a
blackface performance in it now let's
say that you're a big lib and you want
to do that you say okay yeah well we
actually do have to cancel that whole
genre of
character including the black performers
who put on a kind of black-faced show
because it's offensive and and uh
portrays negative stereotypes and
whatever are you going to cancel Tracy
Morgan Tracy Morgan great comedian his
characters throughout the years have
been hilarious one of the great
characters on Rock which is one of the
great sitcoms you're going he is
effectively doing a minstral performance
and in fact they even allude to that on
a later episode of 30 Rock where Alec
Baldwin as a white guy does a
performance of Tracy Morgan's family
which is largely in the minstral
tradition do are we going to cancel that
maybe they're probably going to cancel
that episode we're going to cancel Tracy
Morgan how about how about a lot of
those shows in the
1970s that were great shows but which
were sometimes accused of miny shows
like Good Times The Jeffersons Sanford
and Son we going to are we going to
cancel those I don't know just seems to
me kind of crazy one time I was in a in
a Cadillac Uber in LA and I it was a
Cadillac so I had a feeling the driver
was a conservative and that the driver
was a black guy and there was one of
these uh controversy non controversies
over blackface that came on and he comes
on the radio or whatever he was
listening to podcast and he said ah man
that's that's crazy and I said what's
crazy wearing blackface he goes huh
black oh blackface is fine man it's fine
as long as it's all in good fun I don't
care you want to dress up like some
other guy of the opposite race who cares
that's all fun as long as it's in good
good spirits and I think that's actually
the distinction here but the libs are
not doing anything in good spirits or
good faith they're attacking a little
kid for wearing his team's colors to a
football game a football game that's
already going to have a lot of cameras
on it because Taylor Swift Swift's
boyfriend plays for the team absolutely
despicable speaking of sports
journalism Sports illustrate is is in
Hot
Water Sports Illustrated is in hot water
because futurism another outlet has just
done an investigation and accused Sports
Illustrated of publishing
articles generated by
AI That's right futurism then asked
Sports Illustrated about the alleged AI
written articles and then they deleted
everything oo they got them right it's a
long expose I didn't read the whole
thing I don't really see why I would
because I don't see why I would care I
hate to defend Sports Illustrated Sports
Illustrated has gone super
lib why do I care if some computer wrote
up content if I like the content I
probably don't I don't read Sports
Illustrated
but if if the content itself is
fine why do I care if it was written by
a computer or by a human being I'll go
further I bet that AI is capable of
writing much more interesting
instructive edifying articles than many
so-called journalists
today many so-called journalists are
just effectively inferior robots what do
they get they get their talking points
they they were indoctrinated in some lib
school and and they know things and they
repeat the same tired cliches and they
just use whatever phrases are
fashionable on the woke left and they
Ram it all in there into some stupid
article well okay if I'm going to if I'm
going to read robot generated journalism
anyway why wouldn't I go for the real
robot that's got the latest AI rather
than the robot who was churned out of
some liberal University I see no problem
with it
whatsoever I I I almost could maybe
start to see a problem if we're talking
about some great work of literature even
there I don't I don't really care that
much but if we're talking about some
magazine that you read in the dentist's
office why do I care why is this some
big
expose it's going to it's going to put
liberal journalists out of work awesome
great three cheers for AI where do I
donate now speaking of donations
speaking of your wealth you got to check
out Burch gold right now text nolles to
998 9898 diversify your savings with
precious medals while stockpiling silver
in your home safe with Birch gold grou
special of the year now through December
22nd for every $5,000 you spend with
Birch gold they will send you a 1 o
Silver Eagle Coin for free Tex NOS canw
to 98 9898 to claim your eligibility now
you can purchase gold and silver and
have it shipped directly to your home or
have Birch Gold's precious metal
Specialists help you convert an existing
Ira of 401k into a tax sheltered Ira in
gold for no money out of pocket keep it
for yourself or give something with real
value as a stocking stuer this year just
text the keyword nolles kwes to 98 9898
to claim your eligibility with an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers now is the
best time to buy gold from Birch gold
text noes K to 98 9898 claim your
eligibility for free silver un
qualifying purchases before December
22nd that's nolles cans to 98 98 98
stock up now baby speaking of robotic
narratives Kevin McCarthy was just
giving some debate I don't I guess this
was at the Oxford Union society I guess
that that makes sense he's wearing a
tuxedo botai is a little a skew but he
made an
argument
that is the sort of thing you've heard
from every Republican Congressional
candidate for your whole life this is
the sort of thing that they teach you in
how to be a young Republican school and
it's an argument that former speaker
McCarthy made with great Passion the
problem is it's not true peace without
freedom is
meaningless think for one moment it is
human nature that we all crave peace but
we never attain it unless we have
freedom in every single war that America
has
fought we have never asked for land
afterwards except for enough to bury the
Americans who gave the ultimate
sacrifice for that freedom we went in
for
but the basis of their basis of their
definition is wrong intervention is not
just
military you see I believe the greatest
strength of America is not the aircraft
carriers is not the Precision weapons
America is more than a country America
is an
idea okay we've all heard
this this is very strong 2010 2011
energy but we've heard this for many
decades now especially from members of
Congress and the problem is it's
obviously false America has fought many
wars for land we fought our first war
from land when we took this land from
the Brits then we fought subsequent Wars
for land we fought Wars for land against
the Indians we I think totally
justifiable Wars we fought a war against
Spain and then we got a lot of land from
Spain as a result of that we've fought
War we fought a lot of Wars for land
okay and I'm actually going to be going
into that tonight I'm going to be
speaking at Vanderbilt right here in my
own town uh if you're around I think the
speech is at 8:00 Central it will it'll
also be broadcast on the YF YouTube
channel so you can go check that out as
well but if you're in Nashville come on
by we are going to be
defending such
Wars and we're going to be defending
something that's really under attack
these days and it's the notion of
colonialism the the notion of settlement
we just celebrated Thanksgiving I
celebrated it you celebrated it a lot of
Libs did not celebrate it Thanksgiving
is when we give thanks to God for his
many blessings and we commemorate a time
when settlers came over here and settled
this country and and took land from
people in some cases and set up
important alliances and fought Wars in
some cases and then got the land and
that's the country that we have today
the reason that McCarthy's speech is
frustrating here is one it's so sacaran
we've never taken one square inch of
land from anyone other than to bury our
dead for the totally selfless Wars that
we' fought every single time that's it's
a little sacaran it's a little
overstated uh but the other reason that
this is frustrating is because if this
is if this is really what conservatives
believe about our history then we're
sunk because it means not only does the
left misunderstand history but the right
does as well and so you you now you then
have no party in America that's actually
grappling with with history and that
means also that you're not grappling
with reality and if you're not dealing
in reality ultimately you're not going
to
win you're not going to be able to
defend against leftwing attacks on
colonization and set
and this ISM and that ISM you won't be
able to do it in a way the left
understands history better than the
conservatives do
because the left
has For Better or Worse their own
intellectual leaders who I guess just
For Worse well I'm talking about
Communists I'm talking about people like
Angela Davis I'm talking about Herbert
marus I'm talking about the Frankfurt
School I'm talking about Antonio grami
I'm talking about even more recent
people like uh Sol Alinsky I'm talking
about all the all the leftists who
dominate The
Universities do you want to talk about
history I'm talking about Howard Zin and
the so-called people's History of the
United States That's revisionist History
it's a bunch of nonsense in in the words
of of Mitch Daniels former governor of
Indiana then president of Purdue he said
it's a bunch of excal trash that should
should be banned from classrooms true
but in order for Howard Zen in order for
the leftists to rewrite history as they
have they had to at least have some
inkling of the real history in the first
place and when
we repeat platitudes nonsense fantasies
like Kevin McCarthy is saying here we've
never fought any War for any land
whatsoever then we are absolutely
vulnerable to the left-wing intellectual
attacks we are defenseless we have no
way of fighting them them off when the
libs come in and they say America you've
just taken a bunch of land from other
people and the best the conservatives
can muster is no we can't America's not
even a land it's just an idea floating
in outer space we are a pure abstraction
how dare you and then the libs can say
well okay you're completely wrong hey
how about how about the Spanish American
war how about King Philips War how about
the the Battle of Little Big Horn how
what happened after the Battle of Little
Big Horn guys did you just give the
Black Hills to the Lakota Sue or did you
take it oh you took it right okay how
about this war how about that War oh uh
yikes hm uh well never mind
then hey guys uh if America's just an
idea why do you want to build a wall on
our Southern border uh H you w have an
answer to it it's too bad I don't mean
to knock McCarthy he seems like a nice
guy and this is just what they teach you
in how to be a Congressional candidate
school but it just isn't true really
really weak sauce from now speaking of
schools by the way and speaking of not
knowing anything the education secretary
Mel
Cardona has just stepped in it by
quoting a Republican president but
getting the quote just a little bit
wrong you know we're going to set up
follow-up calls with every Governor we
met with to make sure we're available um
as uh I think it was President Reagan
said we're from the government we're
here to help um there's there are
resources there there's technical
assistance there and there's a Playbook
that could support the work you're doing
count on us as a partner in this our
students are waiting thank
you was that the quote did Ronald Reagan
say we're from the government and we're
here to help or did Ronald Reagan say
it's probably one of the most famous
Reagan quotes did Reagan say the nine
most frightening words in the English
language are I'm from the government and
I'm here to help I think it was the
latter the meaning of which is obviously
the opposite of what the education
secretary
said and a politician getting a quote
wrong even perfectly totally wrong a
politician not knowing anything is
scandalous enough but it's ESP
especially scandalous and ironic when it
is the head of the Department of
Education that tells you everything you
need to know about the state of American
Education by the way this guy wasn't
just some random no nothing congressman
who got elevated by Biden as a political
favor which sometimes happens this guy
was previously the commissioner of the
Connecticut Department of Education
before that he was a an elementary
school principal he's been in education
his whole life he's got four degrees
he's got a Bachelor's a BS an MS an syc
which is apparently some education
specialist degree and a doctor of
education and Ed
D and he he exhibits a stunning
ignorance and I don't I don't want to
attack him too much it's probably not
his fault he got all these silly degrees
the degrees don't mean anything anymore
he want to a bunch of schools the
schools don't really mean anything
anymore and he's running a department
that hasn't hasn't done anything
productive basically ever and now people
are making fun of him because he doesn't
know anything about anything the Reagan
quote was the opposite of what he said
but Reagan was also somewhat wrong in
his quote as that for a cliffhanger
we'll get to that in one second first
though got to talk about my friends over
at prageru right now go to prageru.com
give a tax deductible donation today is
giving Tuesday a national day of giving
if you want a sport an organization that
shares your beliefs now is the perfect
time to give to Prager youu generous
Prager U donors have committed to
matching all gifts made today your gift
will ensure that prageru continues to
reach millions of young people with our
educational entertaining Pro amera
content you know I a prageru host I host
the book club over at prageru I have
done a lot of five minute videos with
prageru I've written and been in a whole
lot of prageru content and I just
absolutely love it as they've expanded
from the 5-minute videos to different
series to influencers to hit the youths
to Prager use educational content kids
content did you know that 70% of young
viewers changed their minds on an
important issue after watching a prayer
you video right now on giving Tuesday
you can not only donate but your
donation will be
doubled one giving Tuesday donor will be
selected to visit the prageru
headquarters in Los Angeles watch a live
taping of an upcoming prageru video and
meet the team that makes the work
possible this giving Tuesday please
support prageru all gifts will be
matched prageru.com make a tax
deductible donation prageru.com
today I love
Reagan I've visited the
ranch I have read the Reagan books I
quote Ronald Reagan regularly I have a
Ronald Reagan belt buckle I love the guy
okay please don't I have strong Gipper
bonafides but the man did get a few
things wrong okay
and in his defense he lived at a
different time he was fighting a
different enemy he was a cold warrior
now we live in a different time and we
need to recognize that we can't just dig
up the corpse of Ronald Reagan try to
reanimate him like a zombie and have him
solve all of our problems and and one
thing one little bit of Ronald Reagan
wisdom that if it was sufficient in the
80s is no longer sufficient is this
quote that the Biden education secretary
was trying to repeat unsuccessfully
the nine most frightening words in the
English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to
help not
necessarily government is not always
bad government exists for a reason
government exists it's a a natural
institution it a man is the political
creature we're a social animal it exists
to enforce Justice and to uh facilitate
our all living together and uh the
purpose of government is not merely to
just totally leave us alone that would
be called Anarchy that would be the
negation of government the purpose of of
government is uh to do good and avoid
evil it's just like our own individual
purposes and government can overstep
this is why we have another principle
called subsidiarity which is the notion
that decisions ought to be made at the
most familiar and local level possible
where they can be efficiently and
properly made and done but there is a
role for government okay and the fact
that conservatives have treated this
funny little Reagan quip as you know the
gospel truth as as the 11th commandment
or something is one of the reasons why
we've lost because we've seeded the
political power to the left and then the
lives wield that political power and we
stand on the side and we Snicker and we
say you Libs you unprincipled tyrannical
CBS you you think the government's going
to solve your problems yeah the
government's solving their problems
we're their problem the conservatives
are the Liberals problem and the their
use of the government is solving their
problem by kicking us out of the Public
Square and harassing us and surveiling
us and taking away our rights and
showing up at our homes and arresting us
for
nonsense yeah the solution to that
problem is to wield government properly
with Justice
and not just seed the whole Public
Square to the libs now speaking of
limits on government there's a clip that
just went viral of some lady in Ireland
this would be uh Irish green party
Senator uh Pauline Riley Pauline
O'Reilly um discussing the battle
between good on the one hand and freedom
on the other when you think about it all
law all legislation is about the
Restriction of fre Freedom that's
exactly what we're doing here is we are
restricting freedom but we're doing it
for the common good you will see
throughout our constitution yes you have
rights but they are restricted for the
common good everything needs to be
balanced and if your views on other
people's identities go to make their
lives unsafe insecure and cause them
such deep discomfort that they cannot
live in peace then I believe that it is
our job as legislators to restrict those
freedoms for the common good
okay obviously conservatives recoiling
at this woman who is ultimately totally
wrong but let's not allow her wrongness
to lead us into another
error which is to reject the common good
we hear this we say oh no here comes
some left Wier with their common good
talk the common good is totally bogus
we need to forget about the common good
we just need freedom
freedom I'm ran Freedom baby uh no no
the error that this woman is making is
not in suggesting that we ought to
recognize a common good and pursue it
the error that this woman is making is
not recognizing that some limits on our
choice ought to be placed by the
government in service of the common good
that's been true in every state ever
throughout all of human
history the error that this woman is
making is in believing that freedom true
freedom and the common good the true
common good are in opposition to one
another they are not they are not in
opposition to one
another true
freedom is as Lord Acton has said and
I've mentioned it many times even Lord
Acton beloved of the Libertarians has
pointed out that true freedom is not the
ability to do whatever you wish but the
right to do what you ought dooso Cortez
the counter revolutionary philosopher
has pointed out that true freedom is
consists in the perfect will per being
able to perfectly will something and
being able to perfectly will something
which is in a way to do what you
want is Con is contingent upon
perfect intellect perfect
knowing this is why this definition
which is probably foreign to a lot of
people who went to Kevin McCarthy had to
be a young Republican school which leads
people into all sorts of Errors
unfortunately uh this definition is
probably a little bit foreign but it's
it's obviously the right one because as
stosa Cortez points out if freedom is
merely the ability to choose between
opposites without any Prejudice or
preference whatsoever with total
neutrality and total as as like that
lady would be using it it total freedom
to choose if that were what Freedom
really were then God would not be free
because God cannot
sin so that is obviously not what
freedom is it's certainly not what we in
the west have thought that freedom has
been for the vast majority of our
history only God is perfectly free
because only God has perfect the perfect
ability to will contingent upon perfect
intellect only God has that we can get a
little closer to that that's through
something called sanctification but this
this understanding of freedom is what
explains that famous John Adams quote
when John Adams says our constitutions
only Built for moral and religious
people this is exactly what he's talking
about our Constitution which secures for
us the blessings of liberty only works
if we are moral and religious that is to
say if we have disciplined our will as
perfectly as we can which is contingent
upon educating ourselves and increasing
our intellect as much as we
can of knowing the right things and and
thereby that
subsequently doing the right things
that's the only way we can have freedom
without that our institution is totally
worthless so says John Adams so say our
founding
fathers what this woman is really trying
to say this Irish woman she she's trying
to say that we need to uh or the good
version of what she's saying is we need
to limit Lous in pursuit of people
flourishing which is obviously true the
error that she is really falling into
here is she is saying we need to limit
actual rights that people have to
support a vision of the common good that
is totally wrong namely uh stopping I
don't know or something whatever
whatever the new liberal hobby horse
is in order to preserve error in order
to allow people to further degrade
themselves in society and fall into
fantasy and confusion we need to limit
your actual rights to learn to know to
speak to live in the right way that's
what's wrong she's got it completely
upside down but the principle that there
are limitations on our ability to choose
that must be placed in service of a good
which is worth seeking in a political
community that part is obviously true we
do not want to throw the baby out with
the bathwater it's amazing how sometimes
a Hal truth can come out to a total
wrong as that woman is proving now
here's a good example of using the
government to fight back Texas Attorney
General Ken
Paxton who has survived a major
impeachment attempt on him has just
initiated an investigation into my
publicists over Media
Matters this following allegations of
potential fraudulent activity related to
the Media Matters hoax that it
perpetrated on X and Elon Musk that
could very well take down the whole
social media platform based on a lie
that Media Matters
promoted now
the moment that that hoax came out Elon
Musk said I'm going to H file a
thermonuclear lawsuit on Media Matters
and I tell you I'm torn on this because
while Media Matters is obviously in the
wrong and they've probably violated the
law they also publicize a lot of my best
content so I you know I'm torn here
we'll see maybe I can just directly hire
my Media Matters U assignes and and they
can just work here out of the daily wire
office uh I love that Ken Paxton is
doing
this
because he's showing that
politicians are not just going to rely
on private businessmen to fix political
problems the the Total Domination by the
left by the unaccountable activist
largely private sector left working hand
and glove with the Biden Administration
so that the the liberal establishment
can can have the private entities
so-called private entities do their
dirty work like we found out in the
Facebook files and thanks to Elon musk's
releases when he took over then
Twitter okay that is a political
problem and the conservatives who have
followed the the usual three bullet
points of how to be a young Republican
school that lead you into all sort of
historical and philosophical error they
say well we just we don't want to get
the government involved can you imagine
if we use the government then the left
might also use the government to attack
us yeah gee you think you think they'll
do that wow what a scary hypothetical if
that had not already been happening for
60 years yeah that would be scary then
wouldn't it but uh I'm not I'm not
worried about that hypothetical because
it's been happening for a long time so I
think maybe we we should fight back the
option is not between uh you know
mutually assured
destruction and
not mutually assured destruction we
they're destroying us that's that's
happening already the question is only
are we going to fight back or not I
really like this it Ken Paxton doing
this is a great corrective to something
that we had heard for a long time you
know we hear this phrase politics is
Downstream of culture which was
popularized by Andrew Breitbart and
there's a lot of truth to it and that's
why the daily wire we we um live that
out because we're in the private sector
and so we make movies and we we make
cigar comp companies we make razor
companies we attack leftwing
corporations and we uh rally and we
persuade the public to get laws changed
and to elect different people and so we
do all that from the culture
absolutely but unfortunately that phrase
has been used in recent decades by lazy
cowardly Republican politicians to Sher
their duties the the Republicans they
get elected and they say hey no politics
is Downstream of culture you all fix
everything not me hey buddy what did we
elect you for just to sit in an office
and collect a decent salary and do
nothing and and tell us that we need the
private sector to fix everything I don't
think so Buster Elon Musk is doing his
part he's filing the thermonuclear
lawsuit against Media Matters he bought
Twitter for $44 billion yeah he he's
done a lot okay the least that the
politicians can do is follow up and
investigate and use their government
agencies in the pursuit of Justice to
help out the private sector which is
leading the way that's the very least
they can do and Ken Paxton's doing it
and I want to see the rest of the
Republican politicians do it too
okay we got to clear the air and when
you want to clear the air you got to
check out envirocleanse right now go to
EK pure.com use code nolles 35
envirocleanse just announced a massive
black Friday discount it has extended
their sale this week the best way to
fight a cold or flu is to not get it in
the first place that is why we got
enviral cleanse for the office the new
science of air purification with their
limited time extended Black Friday sale
you will save 35% and viral cleanse is
an in home air purifying unit proven to
capture and Destroy flu viruses bacteria
toxins mold and allergens from your home
see by the way I went on the road for
Thanksgiving and what happens i' had
been sounding just fine I go on the road
I come back I've got the little sniffles
it's not I should have taken
envirocleanse on the road enviral
cleanse technology is so powerful it was
chosen to purify the air systems on
board Navy ships and Subs enviral
cleanse helps keep our service men and
women healthier it can keep you and your
family healthier too and viral cleans is
the only home air purifier that promises
Better Health by keeping your home free
of Cold and Flu viruses right now it
save 35% during their extended Black
Friday sale plus get fast free shipping
EK pure.com code N35 35% off
ur.com code N35 for 35% off EK pure.com
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Jeremy Smith 8825 who says my great
great great grandchildren will still be
watching the Michael N show just as he
looks and sounds right now thank the
Lord for AI it's true you can you can be
thankful for a I also you should be
thankful for genell that is going to be
the real reason why your great great
great great great grandchildren will see
me looking just as I as I do now it's
genu s the stuff really works now
turning away from conservatives who get
it toward conservatives who have not
gotten the
memo Mitt Romney says that he would uh
prefer to vote for a Democrat than two
Republican presidential candidates who
do you like in the Republican field uh
anybody um you know I I would I'd be
happy to support virtually any one of
the Republicans maybe not vivec but uh
but the others that are running would
would be acceptable to me and I'd be
happy to vote for them I'd be happy to
vote for a number of the Democrats too I
mean would be an upgrade from in my
opinion from uh Donald Trump and and
perhaps also from uh Joe Biden look I
like President Biden um you know I I
find him a very Charming engaging person
there's some places I agree with him but
most places I disagree with him uh I
think he's made all sorts of terrible
mistakes but uh I would like to see
someone else
run okay he's done he's done okay that's
good Mitt Romney former GOP nominee for
president we nominated this guy for
president and he
says that he would consider voting for a
Democrat over two of the candidates
including the leading candidate in the
GOP field he says look I like all the
candidates in the GOP field except V I
wouldn't vote for him but then he adds
another candidate there he says and I
think a lot of Democrats would be
preferable to Trump to Trum Trump's the
leading C whether you like Trump or not
he's clearly the likely nominee and so
is Mitt Romney here saying that he will
vote for a Democrat over Donald Trump
maybe he is I wouldn't be surprised by
that at all and a lot of people are
trying to figure out why why is Mitt
Romney such a squish well in part he's
from massachusett it's do you remember
when he ran in the 9s against Teddy
Kennedy for that senate seat and he
renounced Ronald Reagan he said I I
wasn't a republican during the time of
Reagan Bush I I was an independent
during the I don't want to return to
Reagan Bush you know and he he did that
and he invented Obamacare and you know
he's certainly a liberal his father was
a liberal Republican George Romney and
so he comes from that strain of
things but does that explain it does
that really totally explain it Donald
Trump
in many ways is much more conservative
than any Republican we've seen in my
lifetime but he's also a rich guy from
New York who has certain liberal
positions and you you would think it's
not totally out of the realm of
possibility that Mitt Romney could vote
for him in the abstract until you
remember that Mitt Romney hates Donald
Trump because Donald Trump made fun of
Mitt Romney don't forget Mitt Romney
endorsed Donald Trump in 2012 or rather
Donald Trump endorsed Mitt Romney in
2012 and Romney was thrilled to have
Trump's Endor
said well uh I just end up doing Phil
Hartman's impression of Ronald Reagan
when I try to do Mitt Romney but in any
case Mitt Romney said you know Donald
you're you're a more successful
businessman than I am ha thanks for your
endorsement
ha
and then fast forward he says Donald
Trump's the biggest threat to America
he's awful he's the worst guy ever we
can't vote for him don't vote for Donald
Trump why I think what this actually
boils down to
is one never gets over over losing the
presidency I think that's it I don't
usually get into psycho Babel and I
admit that Romney is kind of a lib
anyway so maybe that explains it but I
think there there is just this fact that
one never gets over losing the
presidency one time when I was a student
I got to meet Michael
Dukakis who ran for president against
George HW Bush in uh 88 and we meant we
we chatted with him a little bit I was
going to ask him what it was like to be
Governor we were going to ask him just
what like to have a career in politics
and right away he starts talking about
losing the race and it was clear it
still bothered him deeply and what would
have happened how much better the
country would have been had he beaten
bush in 88 and things would have been so
much different Bill Clinton ended up
beating him in '92 wasn't that it was a
and George HW Bush was kind of liberal
it was
not wasn't the end of the world here was
it for for the Liberals but you I just
think you never get over it you never
get over that kind of a loss
and you know in some cases it's not
justified I think these guys have to
move on but in some cases it is
Justified like if you're a woman and you
compete against a man in a woman's
sporting event and the man wins I I
wouldn't get over that so quickly
because it's so deeply unjust which is
why the daily wire has a new movie
coming out perhaps you saw the trailer
yesterday if you did not here it
is in a world where women's sports is
being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
[Music]
[Applause]
Year guys this is serious sports can be
your pathway to a better life what like
yours please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient in becoming a winner
maybe you should try it
sometime are you going to move I am
not let's cut to the chase I know you're
not a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you can beat them what do
you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day youing
this is the way the world is now so I
don't know how we kept a LD on this
there were a couple news reports that
came out but we we filmed this movie
about 6 months ago and I can't believe
how quickly the editors were able to put
it together Jeremy sent me the script
whenever it was seven eight months ago
and I read it and I instantly said I
said hey man this is a masterpiece this
this screenplay is a
masterpiece it's just so out there
people the libs are going to lose their
minds over this movie I said no this has
never been done I mean this reminds me
of like all those great comedies of the
mid 2000s that you don't see anymore
because everyone's so offended by
everything and and no studio will put it
out and he said exactly we're the only
people who can put it out so we got to
put it out so we did this movie you'll
see some familiar faces in there uh it's
it's a masterp I don't know how else to
put it it's a masterpiece I it will be
premiering for us in person on Wednesday
I'm very excited to see it in a little
theater it will be I haven't I haven't
seen the whole cut yet I've seen little
dailies and things like that I've
obviously read the script I'm in the
movie but I can't I'm going to see it
myself on Wednesday and then all of you
will get to see it at the Live premiere
event exclusively on daily W plus Friday
night 8:00 p.m. Eastern join daily W
plus get 50 bucks off your new
membership right now go to dailywire.com
subscribe to sign up for exclusive
access this is to my mind the most daily
wire thing that daily wire has ever done
and it's going to be an absolute blast
so check it out you have to be a member
subscribe we also need you to subscribe
so that you can give us your money so we
can keep making movies like this and
keep keep doing all the stuff that we're
doing in the culture which is not cheap
and we very much appreciate all of you
who have funded that and allowed this
thing to really really grow and have
such an impact on our culture and our
politics so make sure you sign up daily
wire right now the rest of the show
continues right now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code NES KS
check out for 2 months fre on all annual
[Music]
plans